I would say that if you mix Jane Austen
and Franz Kafka then you have had silver
saguru
in a nutshell but you have to add a
little bit of myself post into the mix
and then you stir but not too much and
then you have his writings at the same
time his writer of great integrity
doesn't look to the side he's developed
an aesthetic universe all his own and he
is someone who has ventured into a lot
of different genres and he's perhaps
most known for the remains of the day
but if you would choose one favorite I
love out of åland histories which I
think all his books are wonderful
they're really truly exquisite I would
say that my favorite is the Buried giant
was published in two years 2017 I also
love the remains of the day I think it's
a masterpiece
it's a true masterpiece where he mixes
comedy of manners with Bose starts out
as a PG woodhouse novel and ends as
something Kafka asked I would say and
that novel as he said was published only
last year it doesn't matter to the
Academy that this is a living
ridership that is continuing to grow
well the Swedish Academy Awards the
prize for a body of work and of course
it has to be more or less current but
that's a word that you've been used in
all kinds of different ways and of
course this is a British fighter and
there has been criticism in the past of
you
wording European writers and not looking
to other countries but at the same time
because where she grow of course has one
leg in the Japanese culture and has
written about other person who were how
do you in the Swedish Academy work to
not miss the writers that are in other
parts of the world than Europe well we
have a wonderful library we have
wonderful people around us were always
on the lookout for new and interesting
writers and we speak quite a few
languages among ourselves and of course
how many languages that we do not speak
but then we can always ask people to
write us a detailed report about that
particular writer we do that all the
time and of course if the writer wrote a
lot of papers and do you think he has
something to say to a world that is a
bit trouble
well he is someone who's very interested
in understanding the past but he's not
pristine Reiter is not out to redeem the
past he is exploring what you have to
forget in order to survive in the first
place as an individual or as a society
[Music]
how do you hope that the world will
receive this choice that you made this
year will make the world happy that's
not for me to judge we've just chosen
what we think is an absolutely brilliant
novelist thank you